foreign
let's go to
talk to Jacob in San Antonio what's up
Jacob
not much how you doing John I'm doing
dope on a rope man what's up how are you
oh not much could be a little better I
kind of overindulged on Sour Patch Kids
and chocolate chip cookies last night
listen homie listen listen same team man
same team
hey let's hey okay totally aside I I
turned in my final book draft at 1am on
Friday morning it was due at midnight I
was an hour late
listen I got on a scale
it was not dude I had a trash bag behind
me I looked at it after I hit send it is
the most disturbing trash it's filled
with candy wrappers it's absurd and so
listen I'm detoxing right now not in one
of those like got me a special lemon
ginger tea not that bull crap but like
I'm working hard now man to clean my
soul up so my heart is with you brother
Jacob
you feel like that swollen like Just
Stay Puft Marshmallow with me like you
just feel all brawl right yes dude I
know it but they're so good they're so
good okay what's up okay so on the 20th
y'all did a factor your friends about
alcohol
and I've been kind of struggling with
that and I am 15 days now yay dude way
to go
so and it's not a long time but it feels
like it to me no no you don't get to do
that on the show
15 days man is that a win
yeah it is that's a win we're gonna
celebrate it we're not going to minimize
it we're not going to compare it to
somebody else's 10-year token we're
gonna say hell yeah 15 days way to go
man good for you I appreciate that okay
so I'm just wondering where to go now I
find myself
kind of struggling I mean I've been
working out pretty much every day just
I'm trying to find things to kill time
no no no no no no
Jacob your life is not something to kill
okay okay
time I was just I was just listening to
a conversation uh with Peter Tia and and
Rick Elias it was a beautiful
conversation and I think Rick I think it
was Rick that brought up if we had to
every morning deposit money for the
day's time
we would spend it very very differently
our time
but we just throw it away we wasted we
sit on the toilet for five hours we play
stupid video games we just like we just
wasted
I don't want you to look at your life as
something like just to kill until it's
all over
see what I'm saying yeah and I also
that's in that's in like you're in the
phase where it's still minute by minute
right
it is yeah and it's like trying to find
doing things but not drinking like we
did a game night and usually we were all
drinking when we do a game night and I'm
the only one sitting there and I'm like
man this sucks yeah dude you gave myself
better the next day because I didn't
wake up in a hate of course you did yeah
and you remembered everything but also
okay there's a several things how long
you been drinking for
well I'm 43 since I was probably
junior senior in high school I would
guess a long time
um take me back six months ago how much
were you drinking
oh I could easily finish an 18 pack a
weekend less Bourbon and stuff during
the week quite a bit okay quite a bit
what made you want to quit drinking
I just got life
nothing was working uh everything was
chaotic
and I kept thinking I would just drink
to kill the chaos and it wasn't that uh
wasn't working so I'm like well that's
not working and I'm chilling myself
doing it let's let's do something else
okay so what you just said is really
profound and so I'm gonna say it back to
you in a little bit different way okay
you have lived a life since you were a
junior a senior in high school
that you were hiding from
you're trying to cover up cover it up
with a tarp
and the thing about alcohol is it works
really well for that
it allows you to get to the next day and
the next day and the next day and allows
you to thumb your way I mean just kind
of stumble through a marriage and allows
you to stumble through work until you
find your next job and but it works
until it kills you right
until you look up and everybody's gone
and so the the path before you hey quit
drinking right and you've done that you
were on that are you going to AAA you
are you going to meetings no no this is
just okay you have to it's me by myself
you have to don't do that okay you
cannot I I I I can't
you cannot do this by yourself
okay
and I know you want to you can't
okay okay quick pop quiz can you do this
by yourself
no no you said it not me okay you can't
do it by yourself all right so that's
number one
number two once you get Pat out of the
fog and you're in you're two weeks in
it's about another two weeks or so
you'll start to be able to see the world
a little bit more clearly okay and
here's where I think it gets really
existential hard you're going through
the physical hard right now so people
need the doctor's help to get off right
it's tough quitting
where it gets really tough is when you
realize I don't like any of the men
sitting around this game table with me
I don't like how they treat their wives
I don't like the way they they look at
the world they're just trying to kill
their lives too
in the nerd world we call it long tail
suicide
I'm not pulling a trigger I'm just
slowly ticking off the days on a
calendar until this whole thing just
rides off into the sunset
and what you're going to find When
You're Sober is
you got a lot of things to be grateful
for
you're 43 so you're about halfway done
right statistically speaking yeah and
also
how did I get here I don't like my job I
gotta find new people to hang out with
I'm gonna have to right so you have to
rebuild some really important
Scaffolding in your life and that's hard
you can't do that by yourself I wish you
could man I wish there was a way to do
it by yourself if I could figure that
out I'd be a trillionaire you can't you
can't CEOs whose lives fall apart and
implode can't do it by themselves
multi-pajillioners can't do it by
themselves drunks on the side of the
road can't do it by themselves nobody
can that's how we're made we are tribal
animals man
and so what you're gonna have to do is
stop don't just go to another thing that
puts a tarp over your life that just
maybe kills you a little bit slower than
the alcohol was starting to kill you
let's let's get with a group of people
so we can pull the tarp completely off
our life and look at what we got
and then let's start building the life
that we want
Insurance see what I'm saying and that
that's like that sounds crazy doesn't it
yeah you've never even considered that
no
so dude this is your Independence Day at
43 years of age
and it's both liberating and freeing and
freedom is also terrifying
yeah yeah it is you know it's scary huh
yeah I just kind of going into the
unknown
yeah and that's the part they didn't
tell us when we were kids is when you
get to be adults it's all unknown
every adult I know is just making it up
as we go
and if you got real smart kids they'll
call you on it
kids are way too smart yeah exactly
um
how many kids you got
three 20 25 20 and 14.
are they still within your area they're
still in San Antonio area yeah yeah my
my two daughters live with me with a 14
and 20 year old 20 year olds in college
but living at home and then my son my
son he lives out and with his wife in
New Mexico okay I would love to see you
plan an intentional meeting with your
son
y'all meet in Lubbock and
I want you to sit down and look him at
the eye in the eye and say I
had this and this and this happened when
I was a kid
and I've spent the last 25 years running
from it
and because I was running you as a
little boy were always wondering where
daddy was even when I was sitting right
next to you on the couch and I'm sorry
all that changes today
and I want you to put your hands on his
25 year old face and he's going freak
out
I want you to look him in the eye and
say I love you and I'm going to say it
every day for the rest of my life
whether you hear it or not
okay
and I want you to be honest with him and
tell them that you're in a group you're
getting sober and that you are
damn well determined to live the back
half of your life with a reckless
abandon where you're going to love and
be connected with people and you're
going to go on adventures because
I'm freaking Jacob from San Antonio dude
I can't
how does that sound
all right
scary yes and this is the pep rally
speech right this is like the 80s
Montage like where the music's playing
and you're like oh yeah and then you can
actually go to the gym you're like this
sucks like Sylvester Stallone made it
look so great it's not it's awful it's
cold right
yeah
um so the path forward is hard man it's
hard that's why again you can't do it by
yourself
but at some point if you go to if you go
to like a 12-step group or some group
you're gonna have to go make amends
you're gonna have to go look people in
the eye that you realize I did my best
I did my best stuff I provided for them
I made sure they had food I made sure
they had shoes and that's all really
important that's that's Noble that's
part of the deal
but I withheld me
I might do that anymore and what you're
gonna find in that process my brother is
a ton of healing
a ton of healing because my I promise
you you miss him too
and those two precious daughters you
missed them like crazy too
they live in your house and you miss
them you know what I mean here
what do you do for a living
uh project manager for construction
do you love it or do you hate it
I knew it moment what do you want to do
what do you want to do no no well apart
from I I'm a part owner of it so I don't
think it's just I couldn't care less if
you were the principal owner and CEO and
you made 10 million a year what do you
want to do
I don't know I don't know it's something
I've started to ask myself good hey I've
just been doing this for 20 years 21
years and hey you're going to find
you've just quote unquote been doing a
lot of things for 20 or 20 years 25
years
yeah right and you never stop to ask
yourself what am I doing here
and the fact that man
you're a good dad aren't you
yeah oh yeah feel good about that oh
yeah are you a good husband
yes better than I was we all hopefully
we all are right yeah hopefully we've
been married 20 21 years now we've been
married so yeah I'm right there with you
and hopefully in 30 when I cross the
30-year threshold I can look back and be
like man I'm way better than I was at
the 20-year marker yeah
um
even my wife's seen she's made a comment
she's noticed the difference in the last
two weeks okay take her out and do the
exact same thing that I told you do with
your son
okay because my guess is for a long time
you felt completely and totally alone in
a crowded room
no oh all the time and my guess is
you've probably shared a bed with a
woman for 20 years that you love and
that you know loves you but you feel
completely and totally alone
yeah yeah we yeah
a lot of the times yes let's stop that
I I say this with all due respect at
some point that's a choice to hide
I agree I agree and you're gonna have to
practice not hiding because not hiding
is freaking terrifying well I know my
wife's forever telling me use your words
[Laughter]
when our wives talk to us like we're
Toddlers and they're accurate
well she's a school teacher too so even
even better my wife was also trust me oh
my gosh
um
the idea that you are Unshackled now you
should feel terrified by that and I
don't want that to freak you out and
anytime you feel scared about the
unknown scared about vulnerability
scared about driving to meet with your
son and hold him by his face and tell
him that you love him and hug him so
hard that his ribs hurt
you sh your body will be terrified that
whole way
so I'm telling you that to Norm it it's
it's to be expected it's the same as
when you go in for knee surgery they say
hey the next six months after it's gonna
be hard and you go okay I'm gonna do it
anyway because it's right does that make
sense
yeah most people when they're getting
sober they experience this pain this
relational pain this boredom you're
talking about
and they think that they are somehow bro
it's confirming that they were broken
and they always have been and it's easy
to go back to the thing that made them
feel and feel okay which is alcohol in
your case
if you don't replace it with
a destination here's where we're going
with purpose you're just going to move
your addiction right you're going to
find yourself down some pornography
Rabbit Hole or you're going to be
working 180 hours a week under the guise
of quote unquote they need me and really
it's just you hiding from your family
and from people who know you and love
you okay
the goal here is is to create a life
create a a an ability to look in the
mirror and say I'm worth not hiding
because I'm freaking Jacob from San
Antonio and I'm loved and I love other
people
that's that's what healing looks like
cool
yeah
sounds sounds good
you're so full of crap it sounds awful
it sounds awful
yes it does it sounds awful but
I know it's the right thing to do it's
just okay so before the day's over
before today is over
okay you're gonna find a group
you don't have to tell anybody you're
going but you're gonna find a group
doesn't have to be an AAA group or some
big but you gotta find a group it could
be there's any number of groups San
Antonio guarantee it
and there's also quiet I wouldn't say
secret but there's Quiet Ones for
executives or people who are high
profile or whatever like
find a group second thing is put a date
on the calendar with your wife you don't
have to go tonight because it's going to
take a minute for you to gear it up you
probably should write her a letter that
you can read to her
okay okay
the third is get on the calendar with
your son
put on calendar don't do not bail on it
is that cool
that's cool
I I it's been one of my great life
honors to talk to you man you're a brave
strong man it's awesome
and I'll be with you as any any way
you'll invite me in I'm here dude call
me anytime you want shoot me emails if
you want um and I'll walk alongside you
as you as you completely transform your
life I want you to hang on the phone I'm
gonna send you a copy of own your past
change your future the book and I'm
gonna send you some conversation cards
for your daughters and for you and your
wife
because we're gonna practice just
hanging out it's a thing we haven't done
in a long time or ever we're gonna
practice just being in Commerce in
community with one another just hanging
out just doing hangout things
and maybe it'll give you a little bit of
uh reprieve from looking around the room
of your board game buddies and being
like Oh my gosh how did I end up here
I can't wait to see what happens next
brother